Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys are in. As you
can see, I'm cozy getting ready for the
winter. Hope you guys like my jump.
Alhamdulillah. I look like a little
Christmas tree. Alhamdulillah. But
anyways, need to keep warm. So guys, I
wanted to watch show you guys this
video, subhan Allah, of Candace Owens
actually telling us her red pill moment
of turning the turning point for her.
And subhan Allah, it's no other than
brother Basim Ysef. Subhan Allah. So
here's a video inshallah. And subhan
Allah, she says the moment how it
happened on the Pier Morgan show. Subhan
Allah. Pier Morgan, you uh we'll never
forgive you for the side that you took,
but subhan Allah, look how Allah, like
Allah says, you might hate something
which is good for you and you might love
some which is bad for you. Look how that
show of this man who's keep being
biased, Pierce Morgan. Look what that
done. Subhan Allah to millions of people
around the world that her podcast is now
number one watch around the world and
she's a pro Palestinian activist in May
Allah Islam. Let's go to the video
inshallah
>> cuz yeah I remember like it was all over
the place and you know obviously there's
enormous amount of pressure but you were
able to use that to your favor. You get
let go from Daily Wire. You start up
your own thing and you know obviously
this topic is a very controversial topic
when it comes to Zionism, Jewish power
and these other things. Um and it led to
some things. What is what redpilled you
on this topic that made you say I got to
speak up even though this is a very
taboo topic you get you know like you
said deal with demonetization
cancellation losing an employer what
made you say I got to speak up on this
>> I want to get into heaven and I think
people don't realize that that's real
like I think people who are atheists
don't understand that a part of this
whole psych operation was to make you an
atheist because if you knew for certain
that when you die there is more which
there is you would be living your life
differently right you want I want to get
into heaven and so at the very moment.
>> Subhan Allah. One thing that you can see
with sister Candace is she's genuinely
sincere. I genuinely believe wallah if
she opened up to Islam and people
introduced Islam to her that she might
be open to it and she might be the most
loveliest woman on earth etc. if Islam
and we genuinely believe if Islam is
genuinely sincere with see she will come
to Islam genuinely but if she doesn't
and she knows Islam is the truth and she
sticks by her ways because of whatever
reasons
being good and speaking about Gaza if
you are violating the one who created
you and gave you life and created the
heavens and the earth with our religion
if the truth of Islam has reached you
and you deny that's if that's the case
but hopefully inshallah may Allah guide
her to Islam she genuinely seems sincere
and a lovely lady but let's see
>> that I know anything is true I can't
tell a lie. Right? So when I was working
as and giving the example never prayer
you I genuinely first off wasn't up on
the topic of Israel. It wasn't kind of a
common discussion. There was no pressure
on me to get out there and say things
that are and giving the example never
prayer you. I genuinely first off wasn't
up on the topic of Israel. It wasn't
kind of a common discussion. There was
no pressure on me to get out there and
say things that are pro-Israel. I just
genuinely believed it in the same way
that I tell people. Charlie Kirk just
believed it. There was nothing. There's
no conspiracy. He just was like, "Yeah,
Israel, I'm a Christian and uh obviously
Israel has biblical um connotations and
so I I'm I support Israel almost like
it's like periphery."
>> So subh you can see that for them they
never in a million the brainwashing has
been to such they never thought Israel
can be wrong. It was like no no the
given that the the assel the origin of
the matter is Israel was on the right
side and there's a biblical things etc.
Subhan Allah little did they know subhan
Allah how wrong they were. Well, let's
carry on in same goes to
>> literally. Yeah. In the jail setting and
people who attack that and assume that
everyone's on agenda should stop doing
that. At the moment that it kind of
became a and I would say after October
7th and they were kind of demanding that
you take a side. I watched Bassam
Yousef. This this was truly the mental
turning point for me. He went on to
Piers Morgan and it went viral and he
held up this paper where he showed how
many deaths there were every year of
Palestinians versus Israelis and I I
will never unsee that. So let's just
quickly go to those moments of bas and
uh what she said inshallah to see to
seeh what he's actually talking about.
This is the death of Israeli and
Palestinians and it's changing from one
year to year. It's like fluctuating like
crypto. So my question is today what is
the going rate today for human lives? I
mean 2014 was a great year for Ben
Shapiro. 88 Israelis were died and there
was 2329
Palestinians killed on the other side.
That is one Israeli for 27 Palestinian.
That is a very good exchange rate. What
I'm saying is what is the exchange rate
for today so you guys will be happy.
>> And then I had Norm Finkelstein on my
show at the Daily Wire because I was
like, let me go to someone who actually
is not an anti-semite, right? His
parents survived the Holocaust and he's
a professor who was denied tenure for a
ridiculous reason because he is
committed to telling the truth about
Gaza and he wrote so many books on it.
The prime minister of Israel said, "This
is a war against Amalecch. It obliges
Israel
to kill
every man, woman, and child.
That's what it means to invoke
a war against Amalecch."
>> And that to me was like, "Wow." So guys,
subhan Allah, as you can see, wall,
alhamdulillah, look Allah subh works in
miraculous ways. Subhan Allah, brother
Basam, Subhan Allah came out there, done
a video and subhan Allah, she watches
that the whole entire world change. You
know what that shows us, guys? It shows
how Allah subhana wa tala is in control.
You don't have the Islamophobia. They
talk about Islam and this and that. And
this is what I believe, guys. Allah
doesn't need us in the da. Allah does
not need us at all. Allah does not need
any of us. You know why? It took one
woman to do a social experiment about
baby powder. Yes. BB formula and the
entire world's perception on Islam
changed overnight. It shows how powerful
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is and we need
him and he does not need us at all at
all. And Allah subhanana wa ta'ala will
always expose
the liars and the false doers. Okay?
Always. Like Allah says in the Quran
that they say we are peacemakers rather
they are plotterters. They are mischief
makers. Okay? And Allah describes them
to the tea. Allah talks about their
psychology. If you look into the Quran
and study the Quran from the mushri to
the muts to the Christians obviously all
to the Jews to different people even
certain Muslims Allah talks about their
psychology. So subhan Allah look at
Allahh used people to change the whole
narrative. And this is why it's so
important brothers and sisters that when
we come out and we see something in the
da whatever it is those words can change
somebody's life. Look how Candace's life
flipped upside down in a good way and
her podcast is now number one and she is
exposing Israel on a level that they
will do anything to take her out like
they did with Charlie Kirk. So, subhan
Allah, may Allah subhanaa tala guide
Candace Owens to Islam. May Allah
subhana wa tala open her heart because
she seems sincere. May Allah allow her
to see the truth and her good nature and
kindness be a means for her haya. And
may Allah subhana wa ta'ala guide her
and many like her because there are
sincere Christians and Jews out there
and Muslims and whoever that is for that
matter who are here to speak against the
truth. And in Islam we are morally
consistent not strategically. We as
Muslims cannot see strategically this
benefits us. Yes, Christians have been
masqueraded. We turn a blind eye. No,
our religion says morally that is that
is wrong and it will always be wrong. We
invite you guys to come to the one true
religion, Islam, the one true God, the
one true message, brothers and sisters.
Subhan Allah. What I'm going to say is
may Allah subhanaa tala guide her and
those who are there. Subhan Allah.
That's all I can say and sisters. Hope
you guys enjoyed the video inshallah.
May Allah accept it from brother Musf
and bring him close to Islam and his
lord inshallah. That's all I have to
say. Inshallah. Till next time.
label burst.